ABCs of AI F is for facial recognition
facial recognition is a computer vision
technology that uses artificial
intelligence to identify or verify a
person's identity by analyzing their
facial features chances are if you've
ever unlocked a device using a camera
feature travel through airport security
or been Auto tagged in a photo on social
media you've likely used facial
recognition in some form already but how
does it know who I am you may ask facial
recognition typically uses deep learning
algorithms to extract and compare facial
features from images or videos this
includes identifiers such as facial
geometry facial texture as well as
facial landmarks and since there's only
one you in the entire world facial
recognition is often used as a security
measure for Access Control payment
applications as well as additional
scenarios where a person's identity
requires confirmation check out the
links in our description for more info
and resources what other AI topics do
you want to know more about on the next
episode of